aubry's so nice to see you baby
baby you know it's me baby i do know
it's you even behind those glasses i
know it's you
you know you look ver there you go there
are those peepers
how are you i'm fine yeah no
i'm doing great first question is yeah
that's real convincing i'm doing great
where am i that's my question for you
is it says there right says you are in
turkey right now
i'm doing a lot of zoom interviews these
days and sometimes people are
you know on the other side of the
country you are in
turkey at the moment what's going on
what's that all about
well conan i'm uh shooting a movie here
a guy richie film starring me and jason
statham
[Music]
uh we're following all the uh covid
uh guidelines i've been at quarantine
multiple times
but listen someone's got to save the
film industry
yeah well we reinstate them yeah it's
you and statham
in that order if you ask me because i
like you
statham's fine but he's so british
you know i know i'm surrounded by the
british right now
right because guy richie's directing it
and statham's in it does that mean you
have to talk like them
well you know what's funny is i
i don't know this for sure but when i
read the script
i felt like maybe it was you know
written for a british
person and i just and i there's some
words you know
that i don't really say and i've had to
make the choice of like
am i gonna say this like i'm making fun
of them or
right am i gonna commit to this um
and i don't have an answer for that but
um
yes sounds like well i mean does your
character
because i do a pretty good english
accent you know hello
hello
yeah that's pretty good yeah
i like your character stroke victim
station
oh this place is pretty porsche edna
hey we're going to get the terrace out
of his capital
what's up
how the hell did you get past the
audition yeah you know it's funny
because with those sunglasses on i feel
like i'm doing a drug deal
you know it's just how it feels right
now
i'll give you four apples wow for a
hundred kilos of cocaine
that's yeah that's the best deal i've
had i always buy my cocaine i barter and
i use fresh
fruit and uh it's amazing
here in turkey baby yeah well let's talk
about turkey for a second
hotel room is it pretty nice yeah yeah
it's pretty nice
um i would you know
swing the lens around here but i i uh
i don't know what's good on television
or not yeah you don't want to and who
knows we might see something we
shouldn't see you know
but um truthfully i haven't really been
out of out of the hotel i'm not really
allowed to go anywhere
like i said we're following the copic
guidelines and uh
i'm quarantined so i just stay in my
room like a good girl
yeah well okay so you're saying that
you're behaving yourself
following coping guidelines we got all
that you're staying in a nice hotel room
did they give statham a better hotel
room than you or did you get as good a
hotel room as him
you think he's staying at the hotel room
that i'm staying at no way buddy
he's over at the burma
i can't say it because people know
he's got stalkers he's got stalkers
yeah guess what me too okay
so many ladies trying to get a piece of
this that i'm not allowed to say where i
am right now
you know yeah where are you by the way
i'd love to say
but the minute i say where i am nine
women are gonna grab my ass
and molest me so no i can't oh
i'll last you oh sorry
wait a minute i love it now let's try
that again with a british accent
see now i'm gonna get in trouble with
the hotel staff again because they just
heard you say i'll molest you at the top
of your lips
carry on carry on